Chinese President Xi Jinping calls it
the project of the century
China's sprawling belt and Road
initiative sometimes called the New Silk
Road measured in today's dollars it has
already cost more than the US Marshall
Plan that rebuilt Europe after World War
two the World Bank estimates that some
575 billion dollars worth of energy
plants railways roads ports and other
projects have been built or are in the
works with a hundred 30 nations signing
deals or expressing interest from power
plants in Pakistan to a high-speed rail
line in Indonesia it's one of the most
ambitious intercontinental
infrastructure projects in human history
the stakes for the belton road project
are astronomical
both monetarily as Morgan Stanley
estimates spending will total 1.3
trillion dollars by 2027 and for China's
global image on the world stage
China would like to make it feel much
more than I would as President Donald
Trump's scales back US involvement in
international trade agreements she is
using the belton road to position
himself as a champion of global
cooperation development and free trade
but the project is not without its
critics there are accusations that China
is luring poorer countries into debt
traps for its own political and
strategic gain with some countries even
downsizing or completely canceling
projects even as new deals are being
signed several countries have had to
rethink their involvement often after
popular backlash or change of government
or both
for example Sri Lanka borrowed eight
billion dollars to build a new port
couldn't repay the loans and then gave a
state-owned Chinese company a 99 year
lease in exchange for debt relief the
port has little business now but
provides China a strategic birth along
key shipping lanes
Myanmar also drastically scaled back a
port deal struck under its previous
military regime originally to be 7.5
billion reduced to just 1.3 billion
China would like to get somewhat of a
rollback the Trump administration has
sought to capitalize on the doubts with
Vice President Mike Pence telling
Southeast Asian nations the US would not
offer a constricting belt or a one-way
road in the face of criticism President
Xi is doing damage control calling the
project a road for peace in 2018 the
initiative extended into South America
the Caribbean and even the Arctic in
2019 Italy became the first group of
seven nation to sign up brushing off
warnings from both American and European
allies in Asia these are the countries
that approve of the belt and road
project these are cautious and these are
opposed over all the World Bank says the
revived Silk Road has the potential to
stimulate economic growth but with that
growth comes challenges some of the
risks include allegations of corruption
like those the former Kyrgyzstan Prime
Minister is facing and potential for
environmental damage which prompted a
Kenyan court to order a halt to a power
plant being built on la Moo Island a
major tourist destination she who was
dealing with China's own debt problems
and slowing economic growth has promised
debt relief to some African nations and
a top Chinese regulator called for
greater social responsibility in
overseas investments that's the kind of
sensitivity China will need to show and
follow through on if it's to win over
their skeptics
you
[Music]
you